morning what's your overall take on
what's happening with kovid as of today
thanks kay um good morning we're very
alarmed um we have uh just passed just
surpassed very sadly the 1.5 million
death mark
last week if we continue on the current
course
we are projecting a further five over
half a million five hundred thousand
deaths by spring next year that's really
worrisome of course public health cost
the cost to our economies the stress on
our hospitals and communities uh and our
icus of course our intensive care units
so we're very concerned we in the
european region the 53 member states
that who regional office here in
copenhagen serve only 54
of the population of this region are
vaccinated so there's so much work to be
done still um we're not there yet and it
looks like we're going to have a
worrisome
season ahead
what's driving the um resurgence of
covid in in mainland europe is it the
fact
is it the lack of vaccines or is it as
the guy who um
is the chief executive astrazeneca has
said the vaccines in the uk on the
elderly worked the az vaccine worked
much more effectively
well it's partly due to there being too
many vulnerable populations to infection
of vaccination
also we're seeing waning immunity of
these vaccines especially around after
the 30-week mark of the full course
also we've got as i say
47 of the entire population unvaccinated
um and the unvaccinated let me
absolutely clear the majority of people
in ic in intensive care units and icu's
today are the unvaccinated but there are
other compounding factors okay
winter
this is a seasonality uh observation
we're making at the moment
people moving indoors
need for masks a need for more
ventilation masks as you possibly saw
from the british medical journal the bmj
this last week showed a study where 53
percent of transmission
was prevented by mascus we only have 48
percent of the population in the
european region using masks the moment
we saw that go up if we see this go up
we will have see see a reduction in
cases and a reduction in deaths if we
saw 95 universal
mask use
we could project that we would save
about 160 000 lives so there's a number
of factors plus the more transmissible
delta variance which is accounting for
about 99 of the cases in europe today
that's why this is happening
so
wearing a mask would save 160 000 lives
in europe or worldwide
europe
if we saw 95 mass queues we'd see over
160 000 lives saved from the projection
that you you stated earlier
okay and just if i could take you back
to the astrazeneca line that we are in a
lot of the newspapers this morning
pascal sorry art suggesting that his
vaccination the astrazeneca jab um being
used on older people more here in the uk
than in europe that is the reason that
europe is doing not as well as the uk is
well i wouldn't start comparing
different vaccines i mean all vaccines
have been used in elderly populations
there are varying vaccination coverage
rates across europe
and that's why we're seeing this delta
variant this highly transmissible delta
variant find out these pockets of
vulnerability and susceptible
populations i don't think it's useful
that we go into which vaccine has done
better where
what we need is every member of society
vaccinated and of course those that are
particularly vulnerable the elderly um
the healthcare worker of course
healthcare workers are front line uh
those that are immunocompromised uh that
they take a booster when they're offered
one um this is this is also very
important and will make a big difference
um should we be traveling at the moment
traveling but traveling safely um i i'd
like to think we're going to have a
merry christmas but a safe christmas so
i i think
we all hope as to my own children hope
that christmas is on um we believe it is
um that people will be able to uh travel
we hope that they will be able to travel
but i think a bigger question is uh how
they behave when they travel so again
mass queues physical distancing hand
washing
and
adherence to those public health social
measures will be so much more important
over this coming season
but we don't need to worry about um
traveling around europe at the moment
given the numbers that we're seeing in
belgium and germany and austria and the
like and then obviously the travelling
from the united kingdom to europe you
the wh so still feels that that's
acceptable
yeah we think that the travel travel
route should be kept open at this point
um but the care should be taken and of
course um vaccine passports used where
where they're being used where their
they're
i'm southern copenhagen
where i cannot enter buildings without
my my green pass
these these these passes if you like are
actually providing us
giving us enabling us
to
avoid lockdowns and remain
able to move
so that's a very good thing um that
they're used and applied in in many
member states today
you must be frustrated to read that the
british government has destroyed
something like 600 000 vaccine doses
because they're out of date when they
could have been
shipped to
countries that need them
indeed i mean uh what i think uh
we keep we keep explaining to our member
states and and try and communicate as
clearly as possible is
that um we need to keep an eye on
supplies we need to make sure that there
is equitable distribution of these
vaccines and that
if countries plan to for example start
uh booster campaigns etc uh that they
are confident that they will be able to
use the vaccines um that they that they
order that they they are provided
because of course there is only a finite
supply
and what happens and your thoughts on
throwing them away
well it's never good to see a vaccine
thrown away of course but uh this can't
be avoided if you don't have the demand
um for the vaccines or your system
doesn't allow you to present those
vaccines administer those vaccines then
of course they they have to be thrown
away if they're if they're out of date
if they expire
but presumably we could be in a position
via kovacs um where we can transport
those vaccines you know if they've got
the sell by date on them used by date on
them we can put them on an airplane and
send them to africa that's what we're
promoting i mean where we can let's see
that vaccine solidarity um across europe
and across the world indeed couldn't i
couldn't agree more
and as far as the sell by dates on these
vaccines are concerned we were speaking
to our resident gp about that a little
while ago and he was saying
it's different obviously we can't use
them after the um
used by date but how do we know that
they're no longer usable by that day
because they're a new vaccine we don't
know how long they're going to last do
you have a view on that
i don't really i mean a good
manufacturing and pre-qualification that
who conducts on all of our vaccines
basically suggests an expiry date as to
the manufacturers of course
and we adhere to that um
these are new vaccines so still a lot of
as you've just alluded to a lot of uh
studies still ongoing um a lot of
science still to be found around the
vaccines and their longevity um of
course we're all we're all hoping that
we can see vaccines lasting longer and
and of course the um
the uh the waning immunity that we're
seeing at the moment we need to tackle
that um because we need uh of course not
to see that in the future we need those
vaccines to be to be powerful enough to
protect us all in the long term
okay quick thought before i let you go
where are you on compulsory vaccines
mandates
mandates compulsory vaccine it's a
healthy debate right now i mean
mandatory vaccination can but doesn't
always
increase uptake there are lessons of
history here
where mandates have come at an expense
of trust and social inclusion so it's
very delicate but we believe it's time
for to have that conversation um both
from an individual and also a popular
population-based perspective
it's a healthy debate to have
okay uh it's good to talk to you thank
you very much indeed for joining us on
the programme this morning thank you mr
mutter from the world health
organization thanks a lot